assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another episode of
Salaam tiny where are we in the UK to
start
no we are not we are in Istanbul we
already surround oh I'm gonna go
somewhere special where that's gonna be
follow us inshaallah as we review sabe
slap after you so excited
so we are inside the notorious
restaurant the word that in Turkish
means meat so this is what we hear
what our guest that Hashem the inshallah
he's going to be with me today and we're
going to review this place and see how
nice the edge
right so first thing that we do is that
we kind of review the bending of it so
you go through it smokeless see how you
find it
[Music]
Tino Monte okay so I'm gonna speak
English now so he said that on the menu
all of them are the top sellers the new
states issue on the cupola on the table
it melted butter you cook it in detail
away together which one is nice I know
all is nice the bank a nice go sweet
potato [ __ ] spinach same place just
okay go through the app the warning
flower okay give me the image and yeah
just chilly so you have any sources just
perfectly so accordingly
I've been bikini really organic
commercial unsupportive medium rapid
start what something you order food this
is very important and we ordered at 6:48
here so all we're gonna do is we're
gonna see how long it takes when you
start is the call and then between the
starts is how long it takes for the main
new to come here it's really important
with the reason we monitor that is
because between the starts and the main
new if the gap is too long you end up
getting the food with the starter and
don't eat the main so start what we
usually do is this wounded our food we
get to know a bit about our guests so
what was going to ask you is the
speaker's quantico's ever investments
because Connemara hamdullah amazing
debate inshaallah and I'm one of your
students you can tell your students and
what made you come speakers man how long
have you been going let's start with
Harlan even when did you start going 20
years from the time of brothers like of
the time
so yes so you're quite a long 55 inches
deep
so yeah I mean two years ago so there
being a lot of
so it's been very beneficial in terms of
learning from the people who are
experience Jimmy broman sue then really
spun along 20 years Wow what did in this
change was it like the towel has it
become better English in between ten
years with the people is work with the
people's about the fact and how they
came and then obviously the people came
and right I think the main thing that's
noticeable which has changed yeah other
cameras yeah back in the day yeah
because I think that has changed in
terms of spreading the one spreading the
Dawa across the globe I would say now
within the speakers coming here and so
you come on Sunday what is jumping to
commerce and they give you a tower that
was that was the end of it okay
has the misconceptions changed or they
see them you know that bow they still
keep repeating the same old really is it
the same things keep repeating the same
thing regardless how many times I've
been yeah start they come there every
it's like every single week it's not
something new and it's funny enough
because you know even that with Mohammed
hijabs debate that David would which the
janazah of David would be deeply missed
and now he's become a family man yeah in
his career and I'm sure he was wife is
happy that but if you say some time now
anyways million sweetener why do you why
don't they ever talk about the Trinity
if you look at the Christians they never
talk about their own doctor
they're always unlike you know the you
know why do you think that is they can
talk about something they cannot defend
let's put it that way
J Smith's been coming there for like
twenty much longer than I have been
whatever the first time you know
students don't appreciate ten people
and one thing that is a widened one
topic is definitely avoided yeah wasn't
it the the topic on the Trinity because
he didn't talk for the 25 years or
whatever he's been coming there he does
not talk about he did not want to talk
about that that's crazy
imagine if we're doing that for 20 years
and you never hear Tommy for the oneness
of allah from us and you're gonna start
questioning life
what's the fundamentals of religion why
you avoiding it you know especially when
a solution really yeah you know that old
old old debate when they say it was it
quote die then you run over and everyone
started I think if that kind of got you
man I've been from that moment on
disease is avoided it because it'll be
very difficult for the Fisher's to
define something like the Trinity which
is not found in the Bible yeah so
something which is extra-biblical
yeah and that is something that
obviously they will be questioning
we are doing the debate yes and if they
do not have an answer or at least a
reasonable answer to say why God forgot
the most important doctrine of the earth
in the pod or mention in the Bible in it
if you look at the Old Testament the New
Testament none of them speak about the
Trinity or the German yeah there's
always one book it's quite interesting
you know when they talk to us that he
said it's hard for them to answer our
questions
so imagine if one from Allah other than
answer imagine when all this runs out is
good amazing before them you learn
before you start giving Dawa learn about
it that is the basics you know yes the
thing is many people just jump into it
without going the nuances without
knowing the details even here and that's
kind of backfired on them yes because
when they are also questioned they
themselves starting with them
something terrible has happened the
great misreads how how that has befallen
onto the floor but to be honest I wanted
to give him dower in saga of welcome is
over all this is not here is that the
other Bunch
well you never know I might you know
find him and there it's a good thing we
got our cameraman for massive hours yeah
yes I see now what sisters do not forget
to unsubscribe right now but one of the
channels I recommend intentions and mind
okay so the starters came in five
minutes so if you can see I think it's
quite reasonable five minutes is quite
reasonable
I said she understood that we're really
sorry like we did not mean to serve our
dear cameraman he's working out so you
gonna watch
okay I'm gonna have my phone in salad
it's like on your budget
okay guys so this here is the here is
the special
personally I went to a place in central
London I don't know the name but they'll
bring you this meat with a like a farm
and you cook it yourself
how do you find out such a exciting here
do is good let's say of this there was a
lot of be you started that you like it
is nada
for those who like to meet you some
never anticipate to be reported
here we go thank you
as well we're gonna find out exactly
reveal at the end each other for now
we're gonna okay so
if you get that if your company dr. W on
the routines come we ordered
they had it over right so I've tried
before before a living to unsettle that
in Harrogate Green Lanes they do the
best Bach lovelier
so I've tried it let me check oh yeah
okay so I shouldn't see what's so unique
about a little wait for that some
resized him
okay he's asking me let's see how it
tastes and after when they change what
simple checklist and review this place
now
I understand that for the cabinet table
- anyway sorry start are you ready for
the championship with yes but before
games that I've started so I don't mind
the Firebug this is not about you here
I'll just think in and I feel as you
ponder upon myself when I'm in
restaurants when I'm in the stern place
when I see a girl people you know
they're just gonna drink and having fun
there's nothing wrong with I just it
just makes me wonder how I'm grateful
nothing like this and you know when I
was always in the verse of Quran which I
remember specifically I lost my thought
I said that mankind is I'm grading only
that part
mankind itself with witnesses that how
ungrateful he is so it's really
important promises process known as you
know it so many people know we're here
what we want to hear when we want to eat
where to go after you know let's go and
chill here let's go for focus and let's
go for horse riding all these listen and
a lot of people have no other business
afloat
but remembering Allah when they come to
venerable the be placed Allah sister
Eileen is my place a lot however what
time for nanny I find it very profound
it doesn't end if you think about it it
does not a doctor and how could you know
acknowledge all of these famous of Allah
but don't punish yourself for my
medicine see you Noah
you know how would you like how about
seven minutes meat dish I think that's
pretty I think I'm thinking
how is the portion that bear in mind
what you ordered if you had that with
the sides would that absolutely would it
be too much it'll be three less nothing
it for my architect I think that was a
bit more so I had to share it with
others it was more than my yes my crash
my epitaxy yeah okay me [ __ ] my one is
for two people so
it was another I would personally say
yeah it was perfect for three people the
portion housing it was leads of the
position we take the shot down if it's
too much we will see was almost three
months ago so much it was just over my
let's say my opinion some people I don't
know everyone ok subjective isn't it
I'm confused with three or four star
sign what style
okay now price price no I think it's
just one above yours okay I both the
same price yet no mama was 280
oh yeah 280 okay two people
no one was 145 British pounds we're
talking about every pound is about six
and a half
Turkish Liras 625 so we're talking about
fukiko 280 is about 40 pounds for two
people that's that's quite okay nice to
me
I'm easy no one would around 23 pounds
there but mine was only a single portion
you also see yes so obviously but the
double the price I think is for example
in the UK with a reason for a statement
and bearing in mind is quite hope enough
I'm thinking between 4 to 5 stuff I was
even gonna go there but would you say
four or five I think that's a single
portion yes but if I lived in Turkey I
would give this because it's living
consider it Spence Mira but since we
don't live here we're pretending to be a
British ok so that was the price roughly
the food in general how was the food
from the start are they made out to the
desert I love the desert definitely and
so it's it was quite unique I mean they
had the flower yeah which was kind of
warm yes and then they had ice cream
kind of sandwich between the uses of a
flower and then yeah which is quite
unique actually we we have lots of
Common Era and
yes they don't have so I've tried a few
state places I'm gonna give it five I
want to say I'm thinking if I see three
I'm gonna be adjusted it was good
therefore in half so for let's say for
this it that's how we view but now what
makes us unique the salon dining is the
Helana step this is a chest where
there's a lot of problems and since now
they're on the weekends they don't this
one wrong they go to desert places or
places to eat so they want to know so
let's start off with is the menu Huli
hana do we know this one well it's
Turkey the menu is fully anonymous do
this
okay how come here so that won't stop no
how come I think the other point in the
Grand Rapids are if you come to this one
have not apples last one stuff another
historical grain
lastly do they have a simulation if a
problem will it come with a sister or a
family can maybe in a separate place and
you know curtains this is something
there's no story sadly but not all
restaurants cater for it so no stuff for
that so I think I saw that was an
amazing experience we had this obsession
listen to Charlotte I would salsa
organization to donate to and help is
salaam organization as you guys know we
do a real home is our office conceptions
get involved if you wanna see more
debates in the special mission of
subside to exceed our managers channel
my channel and father and father brother
son who is well yes our business are
running what's our confidence for my
head subscribe to the channel about my
sisters do you have a facebook foods is
a dinner yeah I do work Facebook
sometimes we got a group for speakers
corner London we just search for it on
Facebook yeah I shall I will see okay